for over 400 years the problem remained
how could alice design a cipher that
hides her fingerprint thus stopping the
leak of information
the answer is randomness
imagine alice rolled a 26-sided die to
generate a long list of random shifts
and shared this with bob instead of a
code word
now to encrypt her message alice uses
the list of random shifts instead
it is important that this list of shifts
be as long as the message as to avoid
any repetition
then she sends it to bob who decrypts
the message using the same list of
random shifts she had given him
now eve will have a problem because the
resulting encrypted message will have
two powerful properties
one
the shifts never fall into a repetitive
pattern
and two the encrypted message will have
a uniform frequency distribution
because there is no frequency
differential and therefore no leak it is
now impossible for eve to break the
encryption
this is the strongest possible method of
encryption and it emerged towards the
end of the 19th century
it is now known as the one-time pad
in order to visualize the strength of
the one-time pad we must understand the
combinatorial explosion which takes
place
for example the caesar cipher shifted
every letter by the same shift which was
some number between 1 and 26
so if alice was to encrypt her name it
would result in one of 26 possible
encryptions
a small number of possibilities easy to
check them all known as brute force
search
compare this to the one-time pad where
each letter would be shifted by a
different number between 1 and 26 now
think about the number of possible
encryptions it's going to be 26
multiplied by itself five times which is
almost 12 million
sometimes it's hard to visualize
so imagine she wrote her name on a
single page and on top of it stacked
every possible encryption
how high do you think this would be
with almost 12 million possible five
letter sequences this stack of paper
would be enormous
over one kilometer high
when alice encrypts her name using the
one-time pad it is the same as picking
one of these pages at random from the
perspective of eve the code breaker
every five-letter encrypted word she has
is equally likely to be any word in this
stack
so this is perfect secrecy in action